today in this video i'm going to teach
you a communication technique which is
extremely powerful which i personally
use almost every single day you can use
it for oral communication for written
communication for all different types of
contexts such as internal team
communication client communication or
also for instance in job interviews it
is a technique that i've seen
extensively used in consulting but not
so much in other industries or by other
people working not in consulting so
trust that this video once again can
help in lifting the wheel and hopefully
making these techniques available to
everyone else out there as well
independent from where you work so
welcome back to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant and on firm learning i want
to help you to become successful in the
first years of your career so if you
like this please like this video and
also subscribe to my channel to stay up
to date on all my content and now
without further ado let's dive into it
and i will use a little exercise to
illustrate my point and this is a type
of exercise that was quite commonly used
in consulting onboarding programs like
mckinsey bcg or bain because these are
the situations that you will often face
and i will you draw from an exercise
that i already used to illustrate a
point in one of my past videos on top
down communication if you've not seen it
yet i can also very much recommend you
to check it out i will link the video
somewhere above here so that you can
click on it after you've watched this
video so when i read the scenario here
from my screen the situation is that you
are part of a project team that is
looking into market entry opportunities
for new project line you conducted lots
of interviews with internal and external
experts on the topic you looked into
data from the finance department from
the marketing team and you have a first
result that france likely would be a
great fit for that product and indeed
this is because you conducted consumer
research and french consumers will
likely appreciate the offering most you
looked into the competition and
currently there are no strong
competitors yet involved in france and
you also looked into distribution and
warehousing capabilities where your
company at the moment would be very well
set up to serve the french market so so
far so good same scenario as in the last
exercise but my point that i want to
drag out here is a different one because
now the ceo walks in and she asks you
hey what is going on what's the status
with the project can you just summarize
what your preliminary results on that
are
so how would you answer this and this
time now i do not want you to think
about the top-down communication
concepts because we covered these
already in this other video but i want
to focus on a very specific
different point so if you want feel free
to pause the video now and think for an
answer for yourself how would you reply
to such a question but now let's look
into a sample answer what could you have
said in this situation and here let me
just read this out our current
hypothesis is that france would be the
best fit for our product line we looked
into consumer research and the french
consumers will likely appreciate our
offering most the competitive landscape
is also important to consider
and france would be the first with this
offering what's also great is that we
already have solid logistics and
distribution capabilities in france so
again feel free to pause this video and
think about this answer is this a good
answer is this a solid answer so what's
the case for sure that this answer does
comply with top-down communication this
important principle that we introduced
in the other video so is this really the
strongest answer that you could give and
my main point of criticism would be that
this answer feels a bit random it's a
more or less random list of points it
lacks structure it feels like a clothe
line like the result of a brainstorming
where the person was just thinking about
reasons why the french market would be
the best to enter for the product line
and maybe these were indeed all the
relevant reasons why the french market
would be the best but maybe the person
also forgot to mention one or two other
important reasons who knows right so
this is at least not an answer that
would give the recipient a lot of
confidence that this person had it
really all laid out really clearly
organized and really knew exactly what
the most relevant reasons would be so
let's contrast that with the second
example of what you could have had
answered so our current hypothesis is
that france would be the best fit for
our product line this is based on three
reasons first consumer research shows
that french consumers will appreciate
our offering second the competitive
landscape in france has not yet
developed we will be the first with this
offering and third our logistics and
distribution capabilities are way set up
to serve the french market what do you
think about this answer option is this a
better way of answering this i would
argue yes this is the case because this
answer not only follows top-down
communication but this answer also
follows the so-called rule of three you
are clearly starting your answer by
saying that there are three reasons for
that three points three main arguments
and then you're mentioning them first
second third and i hope you agree that
this field's much more structured much
more well organized than just randomly
starting to talk about a first point and
then later maybe a second point and then
another one and another one and it all
feels like brainstorming when you
compare the answers next to each other
they seem very similar what has been
said is very very similar indeed but
trust me that the choice in example
number two will be perceived as much
more structured much more well organized
and this is true up to the point that in
consulting this was so frequently used
that it was considered almost a meme
whenever a client or partner would be
asking you a question you would likely
always say something like yes for sure
so let me mention three points on that
or yes for sure let me mention three
arguments why this is the case or this
is my recommendation and this is for
three reasons you would almost always
try to find a way to structure your
answers in the way that you could start
them with introducing three distinct
points and here the truth is in most of
the cases you did not really had three
points like that ready in your head when
you just started beginning giving this
answer you would in most cases just
start with the first reason and then
likely a second reason is what you would
be able to easily come up with as well
and then just on the way you would try
to come up with a third point a third
reason in my experiences if you practice
this and do this regularly you will
almost always be able to mention a point
number three even though maybe this
third point is not the most relevant the
most important one that you could have
said but i do know that the biggest fear
that people have when answering
questions like this is that they cannot
come up with a third point on the way so
let me share two things that you can
almost always say the third point if you
really cannot come up with anything else
that is more content related on the way
and the first suggestion is to talk
about next steps so what you can almost
always say the third point is what will
you do next what are the next things you
will look at when is the next meeting
where you need to have this already
talking about next steps is so easy
because there's almost always a next
step you're almost never completely
finished with a piece of work on an
analysis so definitely something that
should be able to help you out here and
my second suggestion would be to talk
about risks or downsides or doubts that
you still have so maybe you looked into
something you are coming to a conclusion
and you're talking about point one and
point two of that conclusion but then in
most cases there will be something where
maybe you will need to look into further
you're not 100 sure about or you see a
certain risk a dependency where your
progress is dependent on the work of
another person maybe another colleague
or another client so these are things
that you should always be able to say as
a point number three if you really
cannot come up with anything else that
would make sense this rule of three is
really extremely powerful and very very
often used in consulting by the way not
only by associates or project leads so
maybe the more junior consultants but
especially also by the partners you will
see partners and senior partners use
this rule of three
all the time both in team communication
but also in communication to the clients
so trust that this alone should be
something that should make you think
whether this isn't maybe worth at least
trying for you for your drug routines
this way but of course i would also be
interested in your experiences what do
you think about the rule of three did
you already use it in the past where
does it work well maybe doesn't it work
that well let us know in the comments i
trust this will be helpful for every
single person in the firm learning
community so if you took any value out
of this video please destroy the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications to stay up to date on
all my content big big thanks to all the
members of firm learning you're really
helping me out here on the channel
thanks for that and feel free to also
follow me on linkedin instagram tick
tock or twitch you'll find links to my
associates below in the video
description i release videos every
single saturday so see you again next
week until then bye bye all the best to
you this is jaime from firm learning